- I'm gonna ask you what you
want to hear a rap about.
Two women over there are
excited, the rest of you,
think of a word, think
of a topic or phrase,
you'd like to hear a rap about.
- [Woman 1] Feet!
- One second, one second.
(audience laughter)
No food, no animals, nothing too boring.
The best suggestion ever was a German man,
who said "a day into the life
of an Aztec High Priest."
(audience laughter)
So, with that, we'll get some suggestions.
Someone over there said
feet, feet is pretty simple.
So why don't you expand on
that with some adjectives?
Means describing words.
(audience laughter)
Anyone else can help them.
- [Woman 2] Hammertoe.
- [Woman 3] One really dirty,
slimy foot found on a train.
(laughter)
- So many adjectives, so you said so lot,
but someone before that said
hammertoe, which I like,
which is, yeah, cool, hammertoes.
And people over here, what
do you want a rap about?
- [Woman 4] Dog on a tree.
- [Man 1] Barbwire foot.
- No, it's not like we take the word foot
and then add five adjectives and do a rap.
You're still, when did you
say, "found on the train?"
- [Woman 3] I did, I
said a dirty, slimy foot,
you find on the train.
- On a train?
- [Woman 3] Where else would you find it?
(audience laughter)
- A foot, a human foot.
This, on a train?
Are you thinking of a shoe?
(audience laughter)
Finding a dirty, slimy foot
on a train, hammertoes.
Middle, what do I rap
about, middle of the room?
No more feet.
- [Man 2] AIDS.
- AIDS?
(audience laughter)
- Yeah, you hate him now, you just.
Okay.
- [Man 3] Queen Elizabeth.
- Yeah.
People over here,
try and be better than
all these terrible people.
- [Man 3] Queen Elizabeth.
- Queen Elizabeth, The
First or The Second?
- [Man 3] Second.
- The second, cool, thank you.
(audience laughter)
- And as over here, what do I rap about?
- [Woman 4] Queen Elizabeth's feet.
(audience laughter)
- I am this close to not
doing the finale of the show.
Because, I hate you all.
Right, so it's a freestyle rap,
that's a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on suggestions.
Remember, I've not prepared or rehearsed.
Let's remind ourselves,
because we've got a hammertoe,
a dirty, slimy, nasty
foot found on a train,
Queen Elizabeth, Queen
Elizabeth's feet, and AIDS.
(audience laughter)
And let's try and do this, fuck.
(laughter)
I hate you so much, right.
♪ Started out, but I treat it nicely ♪
♪ AIDS, coming out developing with HIV ♪
♪ You're laughing, arms
crossed, lady beside you ♪
♪ Like, why you talking about
Immunodeficiency Virus ♪
♪ Quiet, you have a Deficiency Syndrome ♪
♪ Where's it at, where's it coming from ♪
♪ When that's a home, if you
watch the recent movie on HBO ♪
♪ Its a sin then AIDS will, you'll know ♪
♪ Coming out of the 80's ♪
♪ People ignoring it ♪
♪ They were like devastated
out in San Francisco ♪
♪ A whole generation of gay men died ♪
♪ And you're just here
like "End the night!" ♪
(crowd cheering)
♪ With the rock Barbie ♪
♪ Yeah I think its funny ♪
♪ Nah I think you'll never
be funny, take your money ♪
♪ Here's a little
punishment, its your phone ♪
♪ I'm gonna put a little
bit of beer with the salt ♪
♪ Why did I do that ♪
♪ Sorry, to me it tasted like nasty ♪
♪ like sucking on feet but ♪
♪ Who's it on and look down below ♪
♪ I'm like what's the
deal with your nasty toe ♪
♪ Oh, don't really understand her ♪
♪ I want to say this
stop it like MC Hammer ♪
♪ Yet they stopped hammertoe,
rather hammer time ♪
♪ Look at my own feet,
I could show you mine ♪
♪ They're actually quite
nice, not contracted like ♪
♪ The (indistinct) feet in
China, how did they enact it? ♪
♪ They broke them down
and they tied them tight ♪
♪ Let me talk about the weirdest
thing I heard all night ♪
♪ You were like "Yo Chris,
get this in your brain" ♪
♪ Imagine this, you just
be sitting on a train ♪
♪ You like "oh here's my ticket" ♪
♪ What do I want to do,
a feet just kicked it ♪
♪ Why's it loose over
there, walking I can see ♪
♪ Metatarsal bones and Phalanges ♪
♪ Its nasty and slimy, yeah I select it ♪
♪ Where's it coming from,
such weird adjectives ♪
♪ You like oh' I look
it up, it's the left ♪
♪ What's it say on the
label "Queen Elizabeth" ♪
♪ How did the one foot
get up on the train ♪
♪ And the courage, it hasn't
even got a brain and ♪
♪ I eat knowledge, I
wish that I could be ♪
♪ I would bow down, still
I never bow at her feet ♪
♪ I would like to get the blade
on my shoulder like a knight ♪
♪ If I saw her in the bedroom
in the middle of the night ♪
♪ That really happened
22 years ago, remember ♪
♪ A guy got up there
and tried to climb up ♪
♪ Into the palace, wake her up there ♪
♪ She was like ♪
♪ "I'm Queen Elizabeth,
I'm feeling very scared" ♪
♪ Now, at the time Philip was
alive, he was there like ♪
♪ " right by my side, get out the sword ♪
♪ and kill the intruder,
this didn't happen ♪
♪ Maybe covered up, I can't prove that ♪
♪ And when he's finished,
shedding all the blood ♪
♪ He was like "Stop Lizzie
and start having a rub" ♪
♪ Oh yes, she's like "Prince
Phil you're so large" ♪
♪ And he made blood bath to give
him and her a foot massage. ♪
(crowd cheering)